- The Alicia Keys to success.
(Alicia trumpeting)
I need some music.
(laughing)
I need some music for that.
People always told me don't
you, you should be wearing
dresses and be, and it's
just, wasn't really,
wasn't ever my thing.
As long as people are like, I feel you,
that to me is the most important thing.
I do believe that you can have it all.
You can have everything that you want.
- She's an American singer,
a songwriter, pianist,
actress, record producer
and philanthropist.
♫ I keep on fallin'
♫ In
♫ And out of love
♫ With you
- Throughout her career,
she's won 15 Grammy awards
and has sold over 35
million albums worldwide.
♫ They could say what they like
♫ But all I know is everything's
going to be all right
- Billboard Magazine named
her the top R and B artist
of the 2000s.
♫ This girl is on fire
- She's Alicia Keys, and
here's my take on her top 10
rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal
favorite, and make sure
to stick around all the way
to the end for some special
bonus clips.
And as always, if Alicia
says something that really
resonates with you, please
leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
as well.
Enjoy.
(object thudding)
(invigorating music)
- So what are the Alicia Keys to success?
- The Alicia Keys to success.
(Alicia trumpeting)
I need some music.
(laughing)
I need some music for that.
I don't know, I'm learning as I got, too.
That's the truth and I think that
one of the things I've learned
most recently is just really
to really find who you are.
Find who you are and don't be so worried
about who everybody else around you is.
What people tell you you
should be like or act like
or think like or talk like.
Like really try to find
it out for yourself
and figure out what
really resonates with you
and what you feel, 'cause you know it.
When you know something's
right for you, you feel it.
And so, I think a lot of
times, we talk ourselves
out of it, and we say,
oh, but I don't know,
my friends feel different, or
my boyfriend feels different,
or my mother says this.
And so, we don't get a chance
to really explore who we are.
So that's one of the things.
That's one of my most recently
learned keys to success is
really understanding
who are and embrace it
and be (mumbling).
♫ I keep on fallin' in and out
♫ Of love with you
♫ I never loved someone
♫ The way that I'm lovin' you
♫ Oh baby, uh, uh
- When I sing that song,
every night, I'm like, wow.
Who'da thought that all of
this from that, you know
what I mean, and people told
us that was a bad record
to go with, nobody plays slow
records, it'll never cross
over, nobody's going to
get it, you won't make it,
da-da-da, they told us
everything under the sun.
But it felt good, and it felt
special, and when people heard
it they were moved, and all
the pieces just fell into place
so, it's definitely my calling card.
It's my little baby, and
I cherish and respect it.
I love this song, Girl On Fire.
They all mean something, and
they all came from something
but Girl On Fire is definitely ill.
It came from this interview that did.
I was reading it, and
she said something like,
she's like a girl on
fire, and I was like, uh.
I loved that.
We were in the studio one
day, and I was workin'
with Jeff Bhasker and Salaam Remi.
I was like, I've been wantin'
to write this song called
Girl On Fire.
I'm like, what does
Girl On Fire sound like?
Somehow, we start tossin'
around these ideas and thoughts
and these different sounds
come out, and these different
things come out.
Eventually, we came to the
chords that are Girl On Fire.
And I guess you'd want
me to play the chords.
So the chords are pretty...
(Alicia playing)
That ain't the chord, hold on.
There, there go the chord.
So, it's like
♫ She's just a girl
♫ And she's on fire
So anyway, those are the chords, right?
So, the CP-70's on it, too.
It's like a different kind
of a little bit twangier
type of sound.
♫ Hotter than a fantasy
There go the damn chord again.
♫ Lonely like a highway
We start goin' through all
these different crazy drums
and then there was these loud,
obnoxious, just destructive
drums, I was like, yes,
the Girl On Fire is loud
and obnoxious and destructive,
and free, you know
what I mean.
So, I was like, that's what
a Girl On Fire sounds like.
And then, we just went into the room.
I just had a mic set up over here.
♫ Oh
And it's just flowin'.
It's like one of these crazy
moments that everything's
just flowing, which sometimes happens,
sometimes doesn't happen.
But this moment,
everything was just magic.
We sat down on the couch, we
start writing some lyrics down,
I'm like,
♫ She's just a girl and she's on fire
♫ Higher than a fantasy
♫ Hotter than a fan
♫ Lonely like a highway
It's just flowing, boom, boom, boom.
Then we go in again,
and I just sing it again
from top to bottom, and I
don't know what happened,
but it was like an explosion
of magic fairy dust
that came down, and that's
basically what happens sometimes
with songs, but it's very rare.
I just remember being in the bathroom
(Alicia giggling)
and I'm singing the song, and I'm like
♫ Ah
and it's just going around
and around and round
and round and round and round in my head.
When I left the bathroom,
my husband called me
and I was like, yo!
And he was like, what's up?
I said, I think we just
came up with somethin'.
Mmm.
♫ She's just a girl and she's on fire
♫ Hotter than a fantasy
♫ Lonely like a highway
♫ She's livin' in a world and it's on fire
♫ Filled with catastrophe
♫ But she knows she can fly away
♫ Oh
♫ She got both feet on the ground
♫ And she's burnin' it down
♫ Oh
♫ Got her head in the clouds
♫ And she's not backin' down
Now, what I'm going to ask
myself is why did I chose
to write this song so high.
That's probably what's going to come up
on some occasions,
because I didn't even get
to the chorus yet, and I'm askin' myself
what made me write this song that high.
So, now you'd have to wait for the chorus,
'cause we could have a disaster.
(laughing)
Even when I was just just
starting, I was different,
and I looked way different
and I played the piano
and I had the braids, and I
was straight off of the streets
in New York.
♫ I keep on fallin' in and out
♫ Of love with you
People always told me don't
you, you should be wearing
dresses and be, and it just
wasn't really, was never
my thing.
My thing, I wanted to be
the everyday girl that I was
and be able to relate to
other women and girls,
and be able to just be who
I was, 'cause I didn't see
myself in the music or in
the entertainment world
or whatever.
And so, now, I feel like I
have actually really come
back to that place, and really
recognizing I've always been
that person, and as you grow,
you try different things
and you go different
places, but that's where I'm
the most comfortable, and
that's where I really am able
to be truly myself.
My mother instilled a
lot of principles in me
just by being her.
But one of the things is she
often instilled in me was also
just to see things through to the end.
Don't give up halfway in
the middle just 'cause
you tired, see it through.
So, that's definitely
somethin' that helps me get
through a lot of things.
A lot of people who are creative,
they often get shut down
by their parents, or things
like that, saying it's not
a real job, or it'll
never work, and I'm glad
that I was encouraged by her like that.
My goal is to always be
the realest that I can be,
and bring the best music that I can bring,
and that's the goal.
That's the most important thing.
All the other things
are illusions, I think,
in a lot of ways, but for me,
as long as people can feel it,
like you said, as long as
people are like I feel you!
That to me is the most important thing.
Everything changed when I
went to Egypt, just because
it was a turning point in my life.
You have these points in your
life where you really learn
something important, and
that was a beginning of me,
one of my big lessons
which was about really
even creating the life and
the world that you want
to live in.
You don't have to
necessarily live in this life
of chaos and unhappiness.
What is it?
What life do you want to have and
what life do you want to live?
For myself, at that time,
that was the question.
'Cause I was learning how to
juggle my own personal life
and my professional life, and
how to be happy inside of it.
And so, that was a big
lesson for me at the time.
- What's the perfect day for you?
- Wow, the perfect day for me.
This is my perfect day.
- Do you remember what it was?
You said a perfect day
would be waking up at three
in the afternoon and reading a book.
- Mmm!
Still sounds perfect.
- Back then, and you tell
me if I'm right, it did seem
to be all about the work.
- Oh, my gosh, you kidding me.
It was totally all about the work.
First of all, I grew up with my mother,
who was my everything,
and a single parent,
and she had to work behind
off, and so she also instilled
that in me, because being
a young girl growing up
in the city, you have to be busy
or you're going to get lost.
- [Reporter] What's one song
that still has the ability
to move you when you sing it?
- Every song has the ability
to move me when I sing it,
which is something I'm very grateful for,
'cause the songs that I
write, they're very personal
and they're very emotional,
and I can understand them.
I can understand them, even if
the time has passed already.
I can understand it.
I have to say, I'll probably
say Fallin' is the song for me.
Obviously, I've sung it a
lot, but there's a magic
about that song that is just unbelievable.
♫ I keep on fallin'
♫ In
♫ And out of love
♫ With you
And the way that it
signifies the beginning of
my career and my life, as
I know it in this world.
It gives me chills every time.
♫ It's just a brand new kind of me
- [Reporter] Well, you're
certainly bucking the odds.
They always say you can't
have it all at the same time.
- I do believe that you can have it all.
You can have everything that you want.
If you want it and you
want to work for it,
you can have it.
♫ Don't be mad
♫ It's just a brand new time for me
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I made this video because
a local fan stopped me
in the store and said, "Hey,
Evan, you got to do a video
"on Alicia Keys, she's my favorite."
So, this one is for you, bro.
Now, if you guys have
a famous entrepreneur
that you'd like me to
profile next, leave it down
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what did Alicia say
that really meant the most to you.
What rule had the biggest
impact on you and why?
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Nancy Johnson.
Nancy, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
(object thudding)
- [Narrator] She turned down
her scholarship for a demo deal
with Columbia Records.
Alicia co-wrote and recorded
a song which featured
in the blockbuster film Men In Black.
It was never released as
a single, and her union
with Columbia soon ended.
Alicia then met powerful
industry mogul Clive Davis
who originally signed
her to Arista Records
and eventually to J Records.
- Me and my manager Jeff
Robinson, we looked at each other
like okay, so what are we going to do?
And we believed enough in
my stuff to find somebody
who also believed in it.
So, at the time it was
Arista where Clive was,
and so he brought my stuff into Clive,
and that was the first
time he ever heard it,
and he loved it, and so
he wanted to meet me,
and that was how our
first meeting was set up.
And when all of that went
well, sorry I'm giving you
the three second version
of it, he moved over to J.
I had the option to go
numerous places at that time,
but I felt loyalty to
somebody who was loyal to me
when I needed help the most,
and so we went over there
with him.
I just goin' forward light.
Positivity, good energy.
And I think that, really, I
think you have to really protect
yourself, and you have to
be cautious of your choices
and stuff like that.
But we're all human beings.
We're all human beings
and no one's perfect.
So, I just try to keep
forward with light and love
and that's what I focus on.
I just don't focus on the negative.
Yeah, but Girl Can't Be Herself.
I think that's just been
something that's been on my mind
so much, and that's part of
what this album is all about.
It really started from this
place of completely takin'
down any walls, takin'
down any veils, any reason
to not 1,000% just speak
truthfully to what I was feeling,
and what I feel is happenin'
around me and to us.
And so, Girl Can't Be Herself,
I feel like there's such
a feelin' for us as women,
that there's such a standard,
there's such a high level
of scrutiny that happens
to women and to young girls,
and it's really, really heavy.
It's intense, and it's very
oppressive, and it's too much.
And I think that from the
minute that we're able to see,
we're fed this vision of
what a woman looks like,
or what a woman's supposed
to look like or what
a sexy woman, or are you beautiful,
or are you not beautiful.
It's like whoa.
So anyway, the deprogramming
that has to happen to all of us
for many reasons, but
especially for us as women,
is pretty intense, so I
wanted to write that song
just because that was how I was feelin'.
And so, later on, when
it came back around later
when I was just recognizing
that, I felt like I was in
a lot of ways just becoming
a bit of a, almost like
a bit of a slave to always
feeling like I had to be made up
in order to go pick up my
son from school, go to the
grocery store, go down the
block to meet my friend.
And this was my own doing.
This is something that I
felt that I needed to do.
I didn't want to feel
like that all the time.
I felt it made me feel crazy.
So again, I was expressing
how I felt in my personal
journey, and it definitely
has never been anything
about starting a movement.
Let's all do it!
It wasn't about that, and
it's definitely not about
anyone who does wear
makeup is now something,
it's not about that.
It's definitely like I want
women to feel empowered
to do what they feel
is best for themselves.
Not because your man told
you and your daddy told you
and your homegirl said, oh
girl, you look like this,
or because your boss said if you don't.
It's like what feels beautiful to you?
So that you can just feel yourself.
And whatever that is,
whatever expression that is,
you do that, and do that
fully, and don't hold back,
and don't let nobody tell
you that you're not beautiful
in any way that you want to express it.